all right so my talk to table is a young  girl's reaction to seeing a photo of  herself which she has been waiting for a  long time  take a look  almost there  we're almost there  is that your diapers  I don't know is it yeah  [Music]  is that you me  um that's you yeah  oh my God that is little jazara um  rocking the afro puffs she's finally  seeing her picture of herself on a box  of Pampers her mother says jazar posed  for that picture two years ago and it  was her first booking as a child model  the mom says they've been looking ever  since to see jazara's pitcher on the  store shelves it finally happened last  month when they went to Walmart in  Ontario Canada and that's what happened  oh dude boys  what that means to that little girl well  that was her job she was the child model  right yeah she's like yeah when am I  going to see myself yeah that's amazing